then Howard Danny arsenalfan yes my own
heart you've even got your sign ball yes
and you're a little bi giru he comes
everywhere with me all time so we've got
a big weekend coming up but then I feel
like you can't be an Arsenal fan without
having some sort of appreciation of
ladies football I know they show a bunch
of the prolific that where women's
Arsenal team on Arsenal TV course the
walk-off couple years ago USA versus
Japan got like record figures thirteen
and a half million people tune into that
we're definitely living in the states as
well I feel like yeah yeah I mean
certainly I think for a lot of people in
this country the route into soccer has
been through the wooden stick for the
national getting and obviously a college
level which play to a very high standard
by by a lot of winnings no I think it's
obviously about time they yeah this
FIFA have like I've played a lot of
football games or soccer games America
yeah over the over my lifetime I believe
this is the first time where we're gonna
have women's football in a video game no
not only that I was trying to think of
an oven another time where big sports
franchises introduced yen's and women's
thing I've actually can't think of one
I'm there may be an example but I don't
think I think I was me perhaps tennis
right like yeah not in terms of sports
stuff yeah so FIFA 16 it's gonna have a
bunch of it suck and the type of roster
when we are used to in terms of the
men's stuff but you've seen it you've
played that what are we looking at yes
so I mean as well as the traditional
roster so all of those international
men's club teams international teams
this year four people 16 they're
introducing women's international teams
okay while balding total which crew I
mean it's not tied to the World Cup
which is happening this summer but it's
obvious gonna represent those biggest
teams yeah at the event I went to we got
to play only USA in Germany and they it
feels definitely different you know
women's football does have a different
pace to it cuz I've this seems to be
allowable in running an alarm there's
all this diving yeah that's true there's
definitely a different feel to the
women's game and it's not just skin what
they've done with the women's teams is
really
adjust that overall kind of stat and to
the type of statute you see on women
players so faster more agile and yeah
definitely like the movement on the
women's players feel felt different to
me have they done stuff in terms of
motion capture like models how does that
stuff hair hair well oh really
so what obviously putting women's team
in the game yeah the big thing you got
to do is have well a lot of the women in
the team have longer hair and yeah we
obviously you do have men's team with
long hair but not as much as it wasn't a
90 years no that's true well and on the
women's you got a lot of like top knots
and ponytails and so there's there's
animation on the hair I mean generally
the animations on the players the
likenesses are really realistic I mean
the u.s. national team obviously has
some fairly recognizable faces it looked
and felt it didn't feel like a throw in
or a little a they'd actually gone to a
lot of effort to really represent the
women's game in the right way and so
they were gonna have 12 teams of
international players they've got new
motion capture a new hair and all that
stuff
last question can you play against dudes
no you can't okay so a much like the
official okay and not like a kickabout
down the park yeah at the moment you
can't obviously mix and match male and
females in the same teams or and men's
men's team against a women's team I
don't know how well they haven't talked
about yet and this will be really
interesting to see is what happens with
Ultimate Team overtime yes you know can
you start to build on what of the
Ultimate Team you've got not only
current players but on the Xbox version
you've got legends right so you can
throw in you know and Beckerman Bergkamp
and all of these players with with
current players I'm wondering it and I
think there's a real potential there to
throw in women's play I get Hope Solo in
there okay so long as she's not able to
play the World Cup yeah I mean if you're
gonna if you're gonna have players like
Pele from the past in FIFA Ultimate Team
why not have you know at this point it's
the ultimate fantasy football right so
why not throw women's women players into
that